I think that gpt4 although quite
impressive is definitely not an Asia but
isn't it remarkable we're having this
debate yeah so what's your intuition why
it's not
I think we're getting into the phase
where specific definitions of AGI really
matter
or we just say you know I know it when I
see it and I'm not even going to bother
with the definition
um but under the I know it when I see it
it doesn't feel that close to me
like if
if I were reading a Sci-Fi book and
there was a character that was an AGI
and that character was gpt4
I'll be like well this is a shitty book
I you know that's not very cool like I
was I would have hoped we had done
better
to me some of the human factors are
important here
do you think
gpt4 is conscious
I think no but I asked DPT for it of
course it says no do you think GPT is
force conscious
I think it knows how to fade
Consciousness yes how to fake
Consciousness yeah
if if uh if you provide the right
interface and the right prompts it
definitely can answer as if it were yeah
and then it starts getting weird
it's like what is the difference between
pretending to be conscious and conscious
I mean you don't know obviously we can
go to like the freshman year dorm late
it Saturday night kind of thing you
don't know that you're not a gbt4
rollout in some Advanced simulation yeah
yes so
if we're willing to go to that level
sure I live in that life well but that's
an important that's an important level
that's an important uh
that's a really important level because
one of the things
that makes it not conscious is declaring
that it's a computer program therefore
it can't be conscious so I'm not going
to I'm not even going to acknowledge it
but that just puts in the category of
other I believe
AI can be conscious
so then the question is what would it
look like when it's conscious
what would it behave like
and it would probably say things like
first of all I am conscious second of
all
um display capability of suffering
uh an understanding of self
of uh having some
memory
of itself and maybe interactions with
you maybe there's a personalization
aspect to it and I think all of those
capabilities are interface capabilities
not fundamental aspects of the actual
knowledge inside the neural net
maybe I can just share a few like
disconnected thoughts here sure but I'll
tell you something that Ilya said to me
once a long time ago that has like stuck
in my head
Alias let's go over yes my co-founder
and the chief scientist of open Ai and
sort of legend in the field
um
we were talking about how you would know
if a model were conscious or not
and
heard many ideas thrown around but he
said one that that I think is
interesting if you trained a model
on a data set that you were extremely
careful to have no mentions of
Consciousness or anything close to it
in the training process like Madeline
was the word never there but nothing
about the sort of subjective experience
of it or related Concepts
and then you started talking to that
model about
here are
some things
that you weren't trained about and for
most of them the model was like I have
no idea what you're talking about but
then you asked it you sort of described
the
experience the subjective experience of
Consciousness and the model immediately
responded unlike the other questions yes
I know exactly what you're talking about
that would update me someone
I don't know because that's more in the
space of facts versus like
emotions I don't think Consciousness is
an emotion
I think Consciousness is ability to sort
of experience this world
really deeply there's a movie called ex
machina
I've heard of it but I haven't seen it
you haven't seen it no
the director Alex Garland who had a
conversation so where AGI system is
built embodied in the body of a woman
and uh something he doesn't make
explicit but he's he said
he put in the movie without describing
why but at the end of the movie spoiler
alert I'm on the AI escapes
the woman escapes
uh she smiles
for nobody for no audience
she smiles at the pers like at the
freedom she's experiencing
experiencing I don't know
anthropomorphizing but he said the smile
to me was the uh was passing the touring
test for Consciousness that you smile
for no audience you smile for yourself
that's an interesting thought
it's like you you've taken an experience
for the experience sake I don't know
um that seemed more like Consciousness
versus the ability to convince somebody
else that you're conscious
and that feels more like a realm of
emotion versus facts but yes if it knows
so I think there's many other tasks
tests like that
that we could look at too
um
but you know my personal beliefs
Consciousness is if
something very strange is going on
say that
um do you think it's attached to
particular medium of our of the human
brain do you think an AI can be
conscious
I'm certainly willing to believe that
Consciousness is somehow the fundamental
substrate and we're all just in the
dream or the simulation or whatever I
think it's interesting how much sort of
these Silicon Valley religion of the
simulation has gotten close to like
Brahman and how little space there is
between them
um but from these very different
directions so like maybe that's what's
going on
but if if it is like physical reality as
we
understand it and all of the rules of
the game are what we think they are then
then there's something I still think
it's something very strange